let's take the reverse the virtuous one
who then
falls prey to the dark side yeah how do
we see that happen
oh in my book the power of the dark side
i came up with i think it's about a
dozen
what i call the lure of the dark side
and sometimes uh see one of them is
sleeping with the enemy
you know sometimes
it's just not a good idea to go there
because
you start getting drawn more and more
into it if you become obsessed with
someone who is
on the dark side another way is
the little white lie that can start
snowballing
and pretty soon you're doing a huge
cover-up you know the political saying
it's not the crime it's the cover-up
that we all get so upset about uh
another one is the slippery slope
and you think oh just this one time i'll
you know nobody will notice nobody will
care or i'm doing it for
my friend or my family but i'm just
going to steal this one thing
and then that slippery slope becomes
easier and easier and easier to fall
into the darkness
and another one that we see a lot of is
drinking the kool-aid now
and somebody getting caught up it's some
movement
or a political thought system
or a fanatic religious thought system
and you quote unquote drink the kool-aid
and you start believing like they do
and then all of your ethics begin to be
eroded by
the group's darkness so many many ways
for
uh heroes protagonists like characters
who are more on the light
to begin to fall prey to the lure
of the dark side and i think that just
in real life
that's one of the benefits to people of
a lot of religions because it gives you
the chance to
confess what you have done and
receive grace receive forgiveness
because
all of us have a dark side so even the
hero
has a dark side yes the hero does have a
dark side and i think
what's very good dramatically is to show
us what that could be
what is their temptation or what is
their fear
and then play upon that throughout the
course of the story
and they almost fall or maybe they do
as in the snow piercer character
who actually fell and then has to redeem
himself
at the end there's a wonderful speech
in apocalypse now which is based on
heart of darkness joseph conrad's novel
and when martin sheen is getting his
mission to go kill
marlon brando colonel kurtz the general
who's giving him the mission
says the theme of the story which is
there is a conflict in every human heart
between the light
and the dark between good and evil
and the light does not always win
sometimes the darkness overcomes what
lincoln called
the better angels of our nature every
man has got a breaking point
and you go oh yeah that's brilliant
and so that's what we want to see in our
characters even we want to know
somewhere in the story that they have
that moment that pivot
moment when they could go down that road
and we should be we should see that they
are sorely tempted to do so
you